20 years
all the u.s troops are now out of
afghanistan it's a major moment
but as we mentioned americans are still
on the ground in harm's way let's bring
in our panel molly hemingway senior
editor at the federalist juan williams
is a fox news analyst in trey gowdy
former congressman from south carolina i
want to go around the horn and i might
interrupt you if the secretary of state
comes out and just think about this
moment this time what it means and what
we've seen over the past 10 days trey
first to you
uh 20 years the same group that we ran
off is running afghanistan women and
girls are still second-class citizens
religious minorities are still being
targeted journalists are still being
beaten
terrorists are still killing americans
as evidenced by this week and the best
we can do is diplomatic pressure which
is an oxymoron
yeah molly
yeah that's exactly right the taliban
are bigger stronger they control more
territory they are more well equipped as
a military presence than they could have
even dreamed of being on september 11th
people are very focused on how
incompetent this withdrawal was and it
was and and contrary to what we just
heard uh about how it couldn't have gone
better it it was a disaster and it was
horrible and and awful the lives lost
and just the the failures there but
really we need to not forget that 19 of
the last 20 years of this war
led by woke generals and political
leaders who moved to nation building
instead of instead of having proper
metrics for success of how to defeat an
enemy
they caused this this is the taliban are
in a position of strength not because of
the last 10 days but because of the last
19 years and we need to never fight a
war this way ever again it is one thing
to do this with the taliban it's
entirely another to do it with a nuclear
adversary which you know is something
that we might be facing in the years to
come
you know juan uh obviously the
administration is trying to put the best
foot forward here talking a lot about
the accomplishment of of the airlift of
getting 123 000 out
and
not focusing on too much on the
americans on the ground saying they'll
have a plan to get those out uh talking
about the success that they see of
getting u.s troops out but there is a
lot of pushback you heard a little bit
about it from molly and trey here's a
gop
backlash about how this has gone
we are now less safe
the taliban has more black hawk
helicopters than australia we have
weaponized them just because we decide
to quit fighting doesn't mean the
terrorists go away
so they're still out there they're
invigorated they're emboldened and
excited about the success
they see in bringing america to its
knees
thoughts on that one
well i think two things to say and let
me just say i think this is a
bold headline day for america the
forever war is over i think we
accomplished the goals that we set when
we went in there 20 years ago
that afghanistan was not used as a
terrorist launching site the american
people want this war over
and when you think about the 13 heroes
whose bodies came home this weekend to
dover
you think you know what those people
died in a good cause they helped with
this evacuation to get people out safely
and it's a you know more than a hundred
thousand people all of our military
personnel now gone they are the last
people who will have died in this you
know america's longest war as you said
brett i think the key thing in response
to those quotes that you just played is
to understand that the terrorist threat
is very different today than it was 20
years ago the element of surprise is
gone we have hardened our targets we
have networks of intelligence we have
the capacity which we've shown over the
last few days to strike back at
terrorists in a way that we did not have
20 years ago let me say a couple of
things one is some of the family members
have already expressed publicly that
those marines
uh that navy corpsman and that u.s
soldier didn't have to die that it was
unnecessary because of the way that this
was handled that's their words
that's the criticism that those 13 did
not have to die there was not a single
casualty since february of 2020 prior to
this moment now the second thing is
that this terrorism threat is is real no
matter how you look at it so the the war
in afghanistan on the ground
may be over and the troops may be out of
harm's way there but
juan you know that if it pops up and it
likely will it's a witch's brew of
radical islamic
terrorism there
that we're going to go there and the
problem is is that the intelligence
assets dry up when you don't have
some aspect of ground presence
well i think that we still do have some
aspect but clearly not what we had
previously with our troops there and
with our mission our you know our
embassy there but i think that it's
important to understand
that the mission the mission was to
prevent that area afghanistan from being
used as a terrorist launching site and i
think that we have accomplished that and
again
when you look at the reality on the
ground and say that there are americans
there there are a lot of americans
apparently out of that 250 who choose to
be there most of those who are left
there
uh in terms of the afghans are people
who wanted to get out but we just
couldn't manage it and i think that when
you look at this and you look at four
presidents brett you look at president
bush who chose to go in there and didn't
know how to get out you look at
president obama uh you know he put more
troops in but it was like a band-aid he
really didn't know how to get out
president trump negotiated with the
taliban
that's uh you know and now president
biden underestimated the the strength of
the afghan government there are a lot of
mistakes here all right trey last word
i'm just trying to process how
afghanistan is no longer a launching
site for terrorism with the 13 coffins
that i saw at dover air force base so
apparently it still is a launching pad
for terrorism because 13 of our soldiers
were killed within the past week
panel we'll have you back in a bit hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else